do you ever wish that you had a tail
you could swing your way to school bake
pies more efficiently and carry an
umbrella while keeping your hands free
the funny thing is you did have a tail
once before you were born
back then you were an embryo an embryo
is an organism that is in the earliest
stages of development before it is born
or hatched early on in the growth of a
human embryo the embryo has a tail-like
structure as time goes on the embryo
grows and eventually the cells that made
up that tail structure shift and form
the tailbone which makes up the bottom
of the spine by the time the embryo is
eight weeks old the tail is not visible
at all
humans are not the only species to have
tails as embryos we share this trait
with the embryos of many other
vertebrates which are animals with a
backbone such as monkeys mice turtles
and chickens scientists call features
such as embryo tales homologous features
structurally similar anatomical features
that two species share that indicate
that the species share a common ancestor
identifying homologous features can help
scientists figure out how different
species are related to each other and
how they evolved studying embryos is a
helpful way for scientists to find
similarities between species
similarities that might not be visible
once the animals are born and grow up
in general embryos of related species
have more obvious homologous features at
earlier stages of development before the
embryo's anatomy becomes highly
specialized
during the stages of an embryo's
development the embryo goes through a
lot of physical changes
the embryo of an elephant starts out
weighing less than a gram and it
eventually grows to its birth weight of
about 100 kilograms
let's take a closer look at the kinds of
changes the elephant embryo goes through
as it develops as an embryo grows its
physical structures change
some structures become visible and
others disappear
for example towards the beginning of
development an elephant embryo has
structures called pharyngeal arches or
gill arches on its neck as the embryo
grows the pharyngeal arches change
structure and help form the ears and
jaws of the elephant and it turns out
all vertebrae embryos have pharyngeal
arches early in their development in
fish these arches develop into gill
structures
in humans and other mammals these arches
develop into ear and jaw structures just
like they did in the elephant pharyngeal
arches are homologous features even
though we can only see this homologous
feature early on in embryo development
pharyngeal arches provide evidence to
scientists that all vertebrates share a
common ancestor
more distantly related species tend to
share fewer homologous features during
both embryo development and after birth
more closely related species tend to
share more homologous features during
both embryo development and after birth
so even though you don't have a tail as
far as i know studying homologous
features and embryos show scientists
that humans are related to many
tail-using creatures because of
evolution